that's crazy you know what we built the  connection on the show and then I didn't  ever expect it I really didn't holy Dean  all brief gonna have to come up with a  hashtag you know there's a moment  recently you guys took a little break  yeah we're back together like for a day  yeah yeah just for a day it's just  everybody's staring at you so it's like  everybody's in that business yeah it's  good it was strong now really strong do  you guys have any rules you live by like  don't go this long without seeing each  other  Polly and I talk we talk every 20  minutes every 20 minutes yeah pretty  much we're best friends  yeah you want to know what she's gone  going on she's nice to know what I'm  going on and she's my person like  whenever something happens I want to  tell her and I'm like 17 pages and he's  like I can't even read this what are you  trying to tell me can you get to the  point where my feelings